لقد ظللنا نتلقى طلبات البقاء في المنزل في
كاليفورنيا لمدة أسبوعين ، فلماذا
لا تزال الذروة لم تأت بعد ، نعم هذا
سؤال رائع حقًا أندرسون والحقيقة
هي أن هناك تأخيرًا لأن الطريقة التي
تسير بها
الأمور لديك  يتعرضون
للإصابة بعدد الإصابات الجديدة في
المستشفيات والرعاية الحرجة
والوفيات ، لذلك حتى عندما تقوم بقمع أو
استقرار عدد الإصابات الجديدة
، سيستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت قبل أن
ترى انخفاضًا في حالات الاستشفاء
وانخفاض في العناية المركزة
وانخفاض في الوفيات و  في الواقع ، الوفيات
هي آخر شيء يتأخر ، لذا يمكنك
أن تكون على ما يرام ولديك تأثير جيد
على التخفيف وما زلت ترى
الوفيات ترتفع ، وهذا هو بالضبط
ما سيحدث في مدينة نيويورك ،
وأريد المتابعة مع أنك تعرف
دكتور.  يُظهر مخطط موراي الذي تعرفه
80.000 حالة وفاة بحلول شهر أغسطس ، كان إسقاط البيت الأبيض يتراوح من
مائة إلى 240.000 حالة في
نفس الفترة الزمنية التي يمكن أن تتغير
إذا كنت تعلم أن الأشخاص يلتزمون حقًا
بالتباعد الاجتماعي ، ويبقى الجميع في
المنزل ، والعكس صحيح أيضًا إذا كان كل شيء
الدول لا تبدأ في البقاء في المنزل
، وهناك تباعد اجتماعي صارم
واجتماعي يمكن أن تزيد هذه الأرقام
أيضًا بشكل صحيح ، أليس البعض
هو أرقامك استنادًا إلى فكرة
أن التباعد الاجتماعي الحالي يظل
كما هو أو  أو كل الحالات
تفعل ذلك بشكل صحيح ، والشيء
الذي أنت على صحته تمامًا وهذا
هو السبب الذي يجعلني أعرف أنني أريد فقط
الوصول إلى المشاهدين وأقول إنك
تعرف التخفيف إذا فعلت ذلك
جيدًا سيكون في  الرقم الذي لا أحبه
ولا أحد يحبه ، لذا عليك أن تضع
قدمك على المسرع لخفض هذا
الرقم لأن البيانات ستتفوق دائمًا على
النماذج ، لذا ما نريد فعله هو أننا
لا نهتم بالنموذج الذي يقول هذا ولكننا
نريد  لخفضها ولكن كما تقول
بشكل صحيح إذا تراجعت ولم
تخفف من ذلك ، فمن المحتمل
أن يرتفع هذا الرقم وهذا أسوأ
شيء ممكن في العالم تريد رؤيته
وهذا هو السبب في أنني كذلك
عندما نقول أننا يجب أن نتبع هذه
الإرشادات ، فعليك أن تأخذ الأمر على
محمل الجد ،
لقد ولدت باكستر بنصف قلب
وخضعت لثلاث عمليات قلب مفتوح
قبل عيد ميلادها الثاني اليوم ، مارلي
تبلغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات وأدركت والدتها
جولين مؤخرًا  إنها لا تحصل على ما يكفي من
الأكسجين ، هذا الرقم منخفض جدًا ،
أمر أطباء مارلي بإجراء قسطرة للقلب
لمعرفة الخطأ ، لقد أجرت
قسطرة للقلب لم
يتم إلغاؤها بسبب
فيروس كورونا في عشرات الولايات.
- تترك إجراءات الطوارئ
مرضى مثل مارلي التي تعيش
في أوكلاهوما دون الرعاية التي يحتاجونها ،
وقد أعطتك المستشفى أي كلمة
عندما تكون قادرة على الحصول عليها.
واحد على الإطلاق لم أسمع
منه على الإطلاق ،
إنه أمر مخيف للغاية حيث
يتم تحويل العديد من الموارد الطبية إلى
أطباء فيروس كورونا ، حيث يتعين على أطباء فيروس كورونا اتخاذ
قرارات بشأن من يحصل على الرعاية ومن
لم تحصل CNN على هذه الرسالة من
رئيس  برنامج جراحة قلب الأطفال
في جامعة كولومبيا ،
اضطررنا إلى ترشيد الرعاية ، كتب أنه كان علينا
اتخاذ قرارات
لم أضطر أبدًا إلى التفكير فيها قبل أن لا يحصل العديد من
المرضى الآن على الرعاية التي
يحتاجونها لكثير من المرضى ، فهذه
عمليات جراحية حاسمة  اختبارات الإجراءات التي
يحتاجون إليها الأشخاص المصابون بأمراض مزمنة ،
والذين غالبًا ما يعانون من مرض حاد
يحتاج إلى الإدارة ، وعلينا التأكد من
أننا لا نفقد مسار عشرات
الآلاف من مئات الآلاف من
الأمريكيين الذين يعانون بصمت
بسبب تأثير  Kovat على
نظام الرعاية الصحية الخاص بنا
في منزل مارلي ، هي وأمها
تصنع أقنعة للممرضات أثناء
انتظار انتهاء الوباء ، فأنا أجلس هنا
فقط أتساءل  متى سنفعل
هذا ونصلي فقط من أجل أن تظل
بصحة جيدة في كيفية إنجازها
لك
كل يوم عندما أذهب إلى العمل
ذاهبًا لذبح زملائي
وأنا أكتب إرادتنا الأخيرة ووصيتنا ،
عمري 28 عامًا.
خوفًا من أننا قد لا ننجو من هذا
الوباء ، ومع ذلك نأتي كل يوم إلى
هذا المستشفى لرعاية مجتمعنا ،
ولا نطلب من
جنودنا ونساءنا الذهاب إلى الحرب دون وسائل
لحماية أنفسهم رجال الشرطة لدينا للعمل
بدون سترة واقية من الرصاص.  لماذا
نطلب من الممرضات دخول الغرف
بأقنعة معاد استخدامها لأننا لا نملك
ما يكفي من الإمدادات ، ثم أقول
إننا نصنع الإمدادات التي نحتضر نحن
نمرضها ، لا يهم عدد
أجهزة التنفس الصناعي التي نحصل عليها إذا ماتنا
ولا نستطيع الركض  أجهزة التنفس الصناعي إذا كان
معالجو الجهاز التنفسي إذا كان الأطباء
يموتون في حالة وفاة الممرضات إذا كان مقدمو الرعاية في الخطوط الأمامية مرضى ، فلن يتبقى أي شخص
لرعاية الجمهور ، فنحن
نطالب باستدعاء قانون الإنتاج الدفاعي حتى
يتسنى لجميع
مصانعنا  استخدام معدات الوقاية الشخصية بالنسبة لنا أجهزة التنفس الصناعي
المواد التي نحتاجها لإنقاذ الناس
من هذا الوباء الذي سيزداد سوءًا